Oh
so I'm interested in the kinds of ideas
that dissolve boundaries that remind us
of what is possible that encouraged us
to think differently to krob at the
adjacent possible there's a great line
that says once a mind is stretched by a
new idea never return to its original
position the kind of things that make us
question everything at Tom Robbins has a
great description he says a cyclone of
unorthodox ideas that will raise every
any mind out of its cognitive Kansas in
other words we are like Dorsey and we
crave the kind of whirlwind of ideas
that will transport us transfigure ate
us and land us in Oz place where there
is room for mystery a place where there
is room for juxtaposition and surrealism
a Rhian chanted world again where
everything is possible that's what
powerful ideas do they are inceptions
they are planted in there and transform
us from within and now all of us are
broadcasters right programmers we don't
just passively take in we produce and
publish and so it's up to us to get the
kind of ideas out into the world that
will spread pneumatically and that will
collectively upgrade man
9 it's our responsibility as the
co-authors of the meme space to tell
great stories to enliven the imagination
to stretch our brains beyond the
cognitive Kansas this should be our
anthem this is our responsibility
you